look at these dots this is what 100
000 things looks like the dots are white
but watch closely you bam they are now a
color called Cosmic latte a color
determined by astronomers in 2003 to be
the average color of everything we can
see in the universe these dots are what
Crayola calls macaroni and cheese but
these next two colors keep us safe
safety orange and safety yellow colors
can be trademarked like Tiffany blue and
UPS's Pullman brown but interestingly
Mattel does not have a trademark on the
pink they use for Barbie in 2012 Market
researchers determined that this is the
least attractive color for that reason
many governments now mandate it on
Tobacco packaging interestingly this
color still has no name the Australian
Department of Health used to call it
olive green but the Australian Olive
Association asked them to stop by the
way my favorite color is seafoam green
you just saw a hundred thousand dots in
10 different colors that means you just
saw one million dots